she's okay now ma'am baby ma'am baby I'm
outside got to open the door kidill you
got to come out
ma'am ma'am are you injured are you
okay I
got are you okay I am but I need ma'am
step to the back of the car please
ma'am ma'am
talk to me talk to me I'm the police
officer ma'am ma'am ma'am
[Applause]
ma'am I'm I'm come here come here
here nope not doing
that seven or eight step it up I have a
hysterical
female possible for
year
ma'am
ma'am get out of the car please I don't
want to okay well it's a car accident
right now the car is yeah well I don't
feel safe you don't feel safe
why
ma'am
ma'am what's
that my
lawyer okay yeah whatever you're not
entitled to a lawyer at a motor vehicle
stop excuse me what did you just say to
me you're not entitled to a lawyer at a
motor vehicle stop I'm not entitled to a
lawyer Fu quars to all units at that MVA
got a second now9 one call
uh one vehicle is supposedly attempting
to leave uh and one party
unconscious uh we have few dispatched
already six to headquarters I have one
car right now one female driver no other
the vehicles in sight nobody fled upon
my arrival unless they to a
lawyer the stupid
cop ma'am can you step out please I'm
not going to step out I don't feel safe
so shut the ma'am step out
please ma'am step out
please that's going to
work forget about that so help me with
the don't
left
that they must have been fighting with
something do you know what she
did
no driver on she's the driver she she
hopped over she wouldn't get on the car
cor trying to cor a
lawyer I'll stand over
here ma'am hop out please I'm not going
to hop out step out come on no ma'am
please step out 15 I can't step out wait
for my lawyer okay we'll wait for your
lawyer but step out please thank you no
I can't ma'am step out I can't why
because I don't feel safe you have to
step out does it please help ma'am step
out please
ma'am I want to to
them
no I don't want this you hang up the
phone no I can't hang up the phone you
have to hang up the phone you have to
wait I have to wait yes you do okay do
you have your ID on you I don't know you
don't
know I you edge water we are Edge Water
that's correct this you know this it's
being recorded okay it's all body can
send a cop
to no we're not sending a cop he said no
cuz he's an asshole okay okay he got
assaulted you don't want to listen right
he doesn't want to listen do you have
your idea on
you man let's start with this what did
you hit can I talk to the law ma'am
ma'am ma'am he doesn't want to he said
no ma'am what did you
hit I am out of the
car
okay
are you okay are you
[Music]
injured please stop I don't want you to
do
anything please Joseph I don't want
anything
please I fucked up my
car I fucked up my
car they don't care they're being
assholes send you a
PL um ring and
colon came need you to step away from
the car okay step away from the car not
the
car touch me I
car
car touch me you get put in handcuff
step away in the car you're in the
roadway you need to step away now I'm
not doing anything you one more time I'm
right in front of the Cross Country
tree the cross step away from your car
you're in the roadway if you don't step
I'm not in the roadway I'm on the
sidewalk from your car don't touch me
don't touch me don't touch me you a shit
how much you have to drink
tonight I'm your friend of the CVS
Pharmacy how much drink I you I got a
Sal to you piece of shit by who yeah
okay whatever yeah whatever if we
started with that we wouldn't have a
problem would we you know what a you
don't know who I am
am you tell us shut the fuck I don't
have to tell you shit wait for my lawyer
you don't have to wait for a lawyer yeah
you do you do have to wait for a
[Applause]
lawyer
[Music]
there was a guy in a white car here came
up and
tried thought she was I thought he was
the one she
hit here for alter mental
status you
promise what's up I really don't think
the airag is going to kill her Her
wallet's right there next to the seat
see just comes back
first no I don't want to talk to them
they're assholes I'm standing next on
the side 48
Choice be advised we're going to need a
host dis location to for a
Tesla
model
X
head
you you need Speedy dry or anything over
there s notified
respond you also run the
that you dispatch the plate number I was
in speaking
somebody on your
computer you there's a license plate
that they witnessed possibly the
boyfriend was you he took off she could
have hit his car they saying she was
driving this was there was a guy here in
a white Crush he was talking like they
were dating and he
left I don't know if you argue
like can't help you if you don't tell us
what
happened
fuck fuck both of you you asshole you're
helping yourself out doing that yeah
whatever 40 that's how you act yeah I do
because I understand yeah I know you do
you want to be seen by the ambulance
they hair for you no no you're refusing
medical attention yeah okay you're not
injured right I might be injured but
well if you're refusing medical
attention you know what shut the off get
out of my face I'm not in your face
whatever we're here doing our job okay
talk I'll my lawyer
okay Priscilla here was involved in this
accident uh doesn't really want to talk
who are you who are
you
helloa this is an EMT she's here to
speak to how you doing I'm an EMT can I
help you um can I just wait to talk to
someone thank you I appreciate it thank
you what do you want to do I just want
to wait to talk to someone you want to
talk to me did you get
hurt in this car what are you waiting
for family to get
here let me put you in the back of the
ambulance
me
stand
[Music]
by can we take your blood pressure and
things like that njl Alpha
96 42
41 you guys
back go back brought here by the police
not by
[Music]
you should be a Jersey
City was hband or something good little
Chase with each
other I'm assume we should
he she's waiting for other family
members to get here so wait we're not
we're here we're off
to what's
[Music]
that never
there we go all
right she got chased by an X we were at
my
place we came outside I was going to
drive for home we got a wedding tomorrow
I can
chess yeah we're dating we're looking to
get engaged and I saw this guy I take
the I know she been threatened by a
former she was atting two different
stalkers one is a former nyp dat and
that's why I said fuck it I'm put my
fucking camera I
my he hit me with the
car that's what he hit me with the car
how heit you with the car I was I was I
was trying to talk to him I was standing
in front of the car I was not and then
he just drove right into me he was here
when I got here I didn't I thought he I
thought he was the one you hit I turn
around to speak to her he was
going I'm not condoling her driving or
anything but like it was not to get out
of there tonight what's that dring
tonight yeah so we it was never I was
taking out to driver home to 79 Street
North up yeah and you can
watch I'm sorry yeah he
just negative I'm outside the caring
with the
individual I don't know how he got I
don't know we you can check the I'll be
honest while
they found the tracker on the car and
they said he's a cop you know what
they'll do to him and that bothered me I
feel ber County would treat different
than Huds then she finally went and
pressed charges and they still tried to
talk her out she's afraid cuz you don't
take it the wrong way you know like she
feels like there's nobody out to protect
her to people ambulance can I talk to
her the ambulance or something um um FAL
report Press Start PR start the the
gentleman shk you know who he is shk you
with the two witnesses going I I got the
information camera uh
and I never met him but I can tell you
that she
filed stop no it's got to stop honey you
can't live this way stop no you can't
live this way I'm begging you to stop
she's afraid the kill list to me yeah
that's stop it no I need information
I'll call your brother I'm calling your
brother he
doesn't J this is beyond the point you
got toop no honey it's wife stop home
syndrome I'll get you a wi we'll work
stop stop I'm begging you to stop I'm
I'm begging you to stop no but you
can't no deal
no don't please I anything no nothing
did you his plate L there was no plate
on the front of the car but you can you
you can look at the we'll get that
from no it's not I mean honey this is
bad look at my
face my face
is
honey YY you can't live that way you
can't live in fear of
people her par her father's a creature I
walk your
street no not stop please stop she's
afraid of the
repercussion she's not going I'm sorry I
know she's been drinking tonight it's
fine but she was I I I really I can show
you her dress on the thing I was driving
home we were leaving her car and we came
out his car was there and then I mean
that's why I'll press chares what what
did you hit what did you
hit honey I'm not honey I'm going
forward with this what did she
hit
what do I
face
incident that happened prior for this
that led for this accident a white Audi
was involved the party operating the
Audi is thator apparently this female
party I'm seene has a restraining order
active against him just Che that
what am
I why why why
ma'am ma'am relax relax relax me can I
go home not yet then arrest
me
feel no not
[Music]
yet
beinged she's requesting I place her in
handcuffs can I call her brother sure go
however you
want
47 is the
Medina
don't to be afraid of
people uh sounds that way according to
the whose deal I just sent
you she she had two stalkers I don't
know if it's a guy a deal or if it's the
cop but she went to North Bergen you can
check
it North ameran issue the TR the orderr
they didal I'm detaining you right now
for your safety yeah okay no I want you
to turn no I'm not going to fuck you
fuck off okay okay you have an active a
training order against a deal shut the
fuck up shut the fuck
up okay how much you got to drink
tonight I'm
sorry no what's the airbag I got hit by
the guy with that she ran from why check
face I'd rather just make sure she's
okay she let them look at you let them
look let let them clean you up at least
please I mean I I
swear looking at the
detective yeah I got him checking
out
um so do you want to tell us what led to
the accident fuck you were you running
from some
you for your life fuck
you call for H yeah it hooks on his
way all right I saw you while I was in
the car we're going to go grab that cuz
your car is getting towed
okay talk to
us prisilla how much you have to drink
tonight prisilla
listen okay I'm fine leave me the fuck
alone I do not want to talk to you
okay fine leave me
alone you really talking I let you talk
what again are you hurt or
injured you kep holding the left side of
your head I'm not make sure you're not
hurt
so leave me
alone where's your
te
for
ask for the gentleman in the video was
that showed
up
what'd you
hit your front TIR is like bent under
the
cars you remember where you hit ask
think a lot gu I'm asking I'm really
asking I don't know what did you guess
if you don't know that's your answer you
can help me I'm trying to do that you
keep telling me to f off and and
everything
else 48 C PD on scene as well as
4S 34
229 look
up
camera
yeah what's up is this how licenses used
to be back in no the it's an expired one
you but I know but I'm
saying f
one
make CH the you
[Music]
said no valid ID in
here what do you
want my license isn't enough well no
this one has it's stand it's
punched you didn't look through it I'm
asking you before I look
through you guys do that's what we do
yeah you want to tell us what happened
tonight no no why
that you have a bad experience with
police is that why you don't like us you
know what shut
okay
assho your ex-boyfriend sold you
tonight that no my job is to find out
what
[Music]
happened
out so what happened
tonight
you can tell it's
okay
[Music]
so the male in the white car in the
video saw you ton
no he didn't do anything well he he
assaulted your your
fiance over there what's that it's a lie
it's a lie that he assaulted him yeah
then how did he get those marks on his
face
you know what leave me alone what's up
sure can you put that on you is that
okay not even
one wait a coup
my yeah yeah
yeah
issue I feel like B
County and so
he said that he
and I don't know if
this black hair like
mustache
yeah
me
and
this person assed you we can help
you no get
back have a seat have a
seat
seriously get off of me get off of me
leave me
alone leave me alone don't touch me get
off of me
you leave me alone I'm just getting away
from you get off of me get off of
me you should have done it in the
beginning you asshole shut
up